It's the only way
to know for sure.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT IN THE
PHOTO SCHOOL SHOOTING PAIRED
WITH THOSE NOW IS FOX'S
MATT FINN.
>> THE BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE POSTED A NEW FAX SITE
WHICH SAYS IT'S MEANT TO CLARIFY
INFORMATION FOR THE WEBSITE SAYS
CLAIMS THAT SOME DEPUTIES WERE
TOLD THEY COULD NOT ENTER
WITHOUT A BODY CAMERA IS FALSE.
EXPLAINING ANY SUGGESTION THAT
SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL OR ANY
DEPUTIES FROM THE BROWARD
SHERIFF'S OFFICE WERE BODY
CAMERAS TO TURNED ON PRIOR TO
ENTERING THE SCHOOL IS FALSE.
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THERE WERE
SOME DEPUTIES THAT COULD NOT
ENTER THE SCHOOL WITHOUT A BODY
CAMERA THAT DAY.
NOTEWORTHY THAT THE SHERIFF
EXPLAINED NO ONE WAS ORDERED TO
TURN ON THEIR CAMERA BEFORE
ENTERING.
IT DOESN'T SAY NO ONE WAS TOLD
NOT TO ENTER WITHOUT A CAMERA.
THE SHERIFF'S NEW WEBSITE ALSO
SAYS CLAIMS THAT CAPTAIN
COMMANDED DEBBIE'S TO STAGE
THEIR PERIMETER TOO SOON AS IT
OF FOCUSING ON NEUTRALIZING THE
SUGAR WERE ALSO FALSE.
EXPENDING IN PART THE SHOOTING
STOPPED WHEN JORDAN ASKED ABOUT
A PERIMETER TO PROTECT A NEARBY
SCHOOL AND THE SUSPECT HAD
ALREADY FLED THE HIGH SCHOOL.
HOWEVER MULTIPLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICES TELL FOX NEWS REPORT IN
ORDER TO PERIMETER, DID NOT ASK
FOR ONE.
THIS APPEARS TO INDICATE THAT
THE 11 MINUTES AFTER THE
SHOOTING BEGAN, EVEN AS NEW
CALLS OF VICTIMS WERE STILL
COMING IN, JORDAN SAID OVER THE
RADIO, NEED A PERIMETER.
AFTER THEIR PERIMETER COMMAND,
EVEN AIRCREWS SAID IT WASN'T
TAKING OFF BECAUSE THE SHOOTER
HAD NOT YET BEEN CONTAINED.
NEW TONIGHT, THE FBI ADMITS THAT
THE STAFFER WHO TOOK THAT PHONE
CALL IN JANUARY WHEN THE FBI WAS
TICKED OFF ABOUT NICHOLAS CRUZ